in kavik a hydroponic greenhouse will
allow su to grow a surplus of garden
foods in the middle of the tundra from
the end of September to the following
June I don't get deliveries I don't get
fresh vegetables if I can grow things
dehydrate or freeze them I'm ahead of
the game on my own nutrition and health
so getting this done it's really
important to me over the top
fluffing it over the top I'm taking an
old tent stripping off the solid colored
tent material I ordered up a new
greenhouse type material 5 plies thick
to go over it what we don't have enough
clothes we're not gonna have enough I
can tell you that right no I only got
one size of my tubing we have to
engineer the return lines and everything
because I don't have it didn't get the
right amount of tubing that I ordered I
can't go to the store and get more we
need 4 hoses well it's gonna be so tight
do it to your top one these don't have
to reach the bottom and take these just
have to be able to yeah the reviews just
have to drip in but this has to reach
now it'll all work water comes in the
far end out of the barrel into this in
here flows in and a greater rate that
it's gonna flow out it's coming out that
instant when this fills up it'll slowly
drain out back into the barrel there it
is that's it ok Ric came up with a
little tundra engineering just what I
needed
we're gonna flood the pipes all right
well I'm just gonna plug it in then
hmm see this running feel it running
come on tiny you can work on there I
hear it yeah yeah it's pumpin
oh there we go yeah holy schnikeys
Batman okay it's full
okay now you would shut it off that's
humming as it drains down the mat will
retain moisture so my little plants will
be able to go will be very proud if my
little dudes make it it may be a little
sue fixed and engineered along the way
but it's working you should say yes
because Rick was a big help
are there little roadblocks yeah there's
a little roadblocks but I gotta just
create a detour you know it's not that I
can't get the point B I just might have
to take a different route so got it